what's going on guys today we're ranking
the eight best quirks with insane
potential
in my hero academia as most of you know
quirks in this series can evolve over
time with practice
or the user themselves may just gain a
better control over it
as we saw with lamilian for this video
i've excluded some of the more obvious
quirks with potential
like one for all and rewind because we
know they'd be around first place and
it'd just be
way too easy don't forget to hit that
sub button
for more list videos like this as i've
done quite a few already
and in fact you may want to check out my
list video playlist which will be in the
description
okay so in eighth place we have
foresight which was a quirk possessed by
sir naitai
may he rest in peace for anyone who's
seen season 4
you'll know that all might's former
sidekick intentionally underused this
ability
and it's possible that if it had a
different user they could have maxed out
its true potential
at a basic level foresight enabled
naitai to see into the future
of any individual ranging from their
immediate future
all the way up until years to come it
was confirmed that the further he looks
into the future
the harder it is to predict exactly when
the events will happen
as we saw with his prediction about all
might's death to activate this power
naitai first has to make contact with
the person in question
and look them directly in the eye the
person's destiny is then played in
nighttime's mind
and the anime makes it appear like a
grainy film strip from this perspective
he can see the person and their
immediate surroundings which allows for
a decent amount of context
from the moment he activates this quirk
there's a 24 hour countdown until he can
use it again
on someone else furthermore once it's
activated
he can view a person's future for a
maximum duration of
one hour tonight i believe the future he
saw
could never be permanently altered and
that even if you tried to change it and
you know maybe you were successful
eventually the future he saw would still
happen however
thanks to deku's actions during the
overhaul arc we now know this is
confirmed to be wrong
and the future can definitively be
changed with that being the case
the potential of this quirk is genuinely
ridiculous like
it's confirmed you can change the future
could you imagine how useful it would
have been
to have a person with this quirk during
the war arc in the manga right now
like just to have someone look into the
future of a few heroes and make some
solid plans to stop
certain events from occurring i think it
would have been perhaps
the most useful quirk if the user of
this quirk was more active with it and
practiced with it more
perhaps foresight's limitations could be
surpassed over time
for example maybe you wouldn't have to
actually touch a person
before you could activate the quirk or
perhaps the 24-hour cooldown period
could be reduced to like two hours and
then after that you can see someone
else's future
while there is no chance that we'll ever
see this potential i think foresight is
definitely worthy of a place on this
list
moving on to seventh we have the quirk
known as vibrate
which is used by yoshindo this guy has
great leadership qualities
and he's super competitive so i have no
doubt that one day
this quirk will be even more monstrous
than it currently is
as the name suggests vibrate gives
shindo the power
to shake anything he touches which he
used during the provisional license exam
to create what can only be described as
mini earthquakes
his tremoring earth vibration was enough
to shatter the ground in front of him
and give class 1a a crap ton of trouble
even todoroki was able to feel the earth
shaking
from the other side of the map we've
only seen this quilt used on large
groups of people
but clearly if he was to use tremoring
earth on a single individual
that person would pop like a balloon
vibrate does have one drawback
and that's that shindo gets an
aftershock after he uses it
however this has actually helped him
build a resistance to vibrations
which is how he was able to bounce back
after gang orca did this to him
in terms of potential i think shindo
could increase the vibrations to a
massive scale and you know i wouldn't
claim to be a one piece fan
but i have played burning blood and you
can't tell me that shindo doesn't have
some whitebeard potential or on some
level
the sixth place quirk with insane
potential is mimicry
this power is used by mimik who was one
of if not the most erratic
member of the shihisikai thanks to this
quirk
he can transfer his body and
consciousness into an animal objects
which he primarily uses to walk around
in this thing for some reason
while he's inside an object he still
needs to manifest eyes to perceive his
surroundings
in regular circumstances he's limited to
controlling things about the size of a
fridge
but thanks to the quirk boosting drug
trigger we were able to see mimicry's
true potential his body and mind were
literally absorbed
into this shiha saikai facility where he
walked the hallways to his will
opening up massive holes in the ground
and also doing a ton of inconvenient
stuff to split them up by warping
buildings like this
i mean mimicry is potentially it could
be one of the best support quirks in
history
as the user can strategically isolate
their opponents
and send them into designated areas to
be dealt with
also it operates as a great stealth
quirk for obvious reasons
either way it is incredibly versatile
and the potential
i can see a lot of things that could be
done with this quirk
the next quirk is one that won't be
appearing in the anime until season 5
so if you want to avoid spoilers then
skip to the timestamp on screen
ranked in 5th place we have landmine aka
the killer queen of the my hero academia
universe
landmine is possessed by curious who is
a member of the meta liberation army now
this quirk allows her to turn anything
she touches
into an explosive device which she can
then detonate at will
the most freakish example of her power
was when she turned the blood of her
subordinates
into bombs so that when toga consumed
their blood
she literally just detonated toga's body
from the inside
thankfully toga was able to survive this
which brings us to the main downside of
this power
and the reason why i think it has
potential but is not quite there yet
the manga states that landmines
explosions don't have much power
and therefore curious goes for quantity
of bombs
rather than the quality of the bombs to
me at least
this was a massive error on her part
because a competent villain i think
would have spent time training the
quality of the blast rather than making
you know rather than making more of them
do you know how much bargaining power a
villain would have
if they could just blow up their
hostages at any given moment like
the heroes can't take chances with
people's lives like that so they
basically have to comply in a situation
like this
at the end of the day with training and
practice i think landmine
obviously the quality of the explosions
could become much much greater
so you could be blowing up whole
buildings for all we know so
yeah i rate it quite highly or at least
i rate the potential of it
quite highly in fourth place we have
brainwashing
which is used by hitoshi shinzo and was
first introduced during the sports
festival
i consider shinzo's quirk to be
something of a secret weapon for the
heroes
and that it can stop any human enemy
regardless of their power level
putting it simply brainwashed lets him
control anyone who responds to something
he says
as we saw when he piloted a whole team
of brainwashed students
during the cavalry battle shinzo's
biggest weakness if you can call it that
is that people must respond to him for
this to work meaning that once an enemy
is aware of his presence
they can consciously choose to avoid
saying anything manga readers especially
will know that the rules of a quirk can
change
over time and with the right training so
if shinzo plays his cards right
in future i think he could maybe develop
two separate types of brainwashing
one type that requires a response but
allows shinzo to give more complex
commands
and another type that requires no
response but activates a more simple
brainwash
like what he's able to do in the present
day let me know down below if you think
that's plausible but either way i think
it's undeniable
that brainwashing has the potential to
be one of the best quirks in this
universe
moving on to third place we have a power
that has already proven its potential to
grow
and that is nato monument's copy quirk
as a fair warning i'm going to go into
some minor manga spoilers here
but it's solely based on how copy has
evolved throughout the series
when we were first introduced to
monima's quirk the way it worked was
that he could make contact with a person
and then be able to use their quirk for
a five minute duration
at this time he could have up to three
quirks stored inside his body at once
and switched between them at will which
made him ridiculously unpredictable
each power he copied had its own
five-minute countdown
which is why he has stopwatches on his
hero costume to keep track of which
quirk is going to run out first
now the potential of this power was
demonstrated during the joint training
arc in the manga
when it was first revealed that through
sheer practice alone
monomer had doubled the duration he
could hold quirks from five minutes
to ten minutes and he'd also increase
the amount of quirks that he could store
in his body
from three to four these developments
happened within the space of
less than a year and i believe that down
the road with maximum potential
i mean he can do way more than this a
maxed out version of this copy quirk
should allow monomer to use different
quirks simultaneously
and combine them everyone else who has
multiple quirks is able to use them at
the same time and combine them in some
way
so realistically speaking i'm kind of
surprised monomer can't do this already
but it definitely will happen
additionally it almost goes without
saying
that the duration for which he can copy
quirks should be his number one priority
in terms of the things that he works on
and you know having already doubled from
five minutes to ten minutes
by the time he's a grown man i see i can
see him having one hour
it's enough time to do the job that you
need to do and it's not too excessive
let me know down below though what is
your opinion of like a realistic time
period
for monomer to store quirks in the
future would it be one hour would it be
a day or would it be like 20 minutes let
me know in the comments down below i'm
interested to see your take on that
the silver medal on this list goes to a
power that i nearly didn't include
because it was just too obvious
but i couldn't bring myself to leave it
out in the end
double is an ability currently possessed
by twice and in terms of its potential
i think it can become even more
formidable than it currently is
if you're watching this then you
probably already know that twice can
create doubles of things
so long as he has sufficient data about
what he's replicating
the only difference between the copies
he creates and the real thing
is their durability and the fact that
they're made from this
grey gooey stuff without giving away
spoilers
we see in the manga that this lack of
durability can be a
big weakness in crucial situations but
what if it wasn't
whether it be by practice or by
experimentation from the doctor
i think that double has the potential to
harden this gooey substance
in a way that each new double is equally
as durable as the last
you can literally have an army of twice
clones who themselves could make an
army of shigeraki clones i mean how
ridiculous would that be
once the issue of durability is overcome
yeah i don't think there's many things
holding him back at that point
now the number one quirk on this list is
something that i think
has the potential to change the world of
my hero academia
and that is creation creation is a power
that lets momo convert the fat in her
body
into a variety of atoms which she then
uses to make inanimate objects
so far we've seen her make things like
cannons gas masks
shields tracking devices catapults and
countless other things
aside from the obvious fact that if momo
acquired the relevant knowledge she can
create anything whether it be
nuclear weapons or quite destroying
bullets or quote destroying nuclear
weapons
i mean the possibilities are endless but
i think there are two additional ways
that her quirk can still grow
and yeah and live up to this insane
potential
to start with she says that her quirk
converts body fat into a variety of
atoms
but at the end of the day you know body
fat is just one
form of stored energy so what if instead
of using her own fat
in the future what if momo can convert
other forms of energy
into her creations whether it be energy
from the sun's radiation
or random things that just happened to
be in her environment
by being able to convert other forms of
energy that would essentially make her
like a limitless creation machine
secondly i know i already used my one
jojo reference earlier in this video
but damn it i'm doing it again because i
think momo
may if she puts her all into it i think
she may have the capacity
to create life is it gonna happen
probably not
but is it possible yeah i think so early
in the manga
the definition of her quirks said that
she could create anything non-living
but as we've seen with monoma deku
shigaraki toga
and a ton of others a quirk isn't truly
defined by the boundaries
of its first definition as long as
momo's big brain can ascertain
the chemical makeup of someone and their
biological makeup perhaps by doing an
autopsy after they die or something like
that
then creation could potentially be used
as almost like a resurrection quirk like
bringing people back to life in a way
if she was able to do this her creations
would be the real thing
inside and out which would be very
different from twice's clones who
like we've established they're made of
this gray stuff which i mean
what even is that obviously momo doing
this would raise a ton of moral
questions
but still is it possible with creation
all she needs to do is understand how
something is made and what it's made of
and then she can do it so i don't know i
think i think it's plausible
let me know in the comments which quirks
you think have the most potential
and i want to give a special mention to
dark shadow whirlwind
and half hot half cold which could have
also easily been on this list
thank you guys for watching that was
everything i had for today and be sure
to check out my list video playlist
which is in the description peace out